please don't suck please please don't
please don't suck so we've had the first
trailer for season two of Jessica Jones
and if you're wondering about my little
intro there let me be blunt about this I
need this to be good for two reasons the
first is Jessica Jones is my favorite
show that Marvel Netflix has put out so
far it's also the last time that I think
they put out a truly solid front-to-back
product and again it's not perfect
there's probably two more episodes in
the season than there needs to be
there's a bit of filler and the pacing
drops towards the tail end because of
that but I still think it's a really
solid piece of television unfortunately
every series since then has either
sucked out right hmm iron fist
or it started out promising and then
either got weaker in the tail end
that's your daredevil season 2 in your
Luke Cage or went completely off the
rails and the tail end which is the
defenders or in the case of the Punisher
I couldn't finish it and I I might go
back and try and finish Punisher because
I've had enough of you folks tell me
that it does get notably better and
later on in the season but I think again
that speaks to me that at this point the
Netflix Marvel shows are training me
that if the shows are good at all
they're good at the front and then they
fall apart so when I wasn't being
grabbed by the beginning of Punisher I
didn't have the faith that it was gonna
get better later because that's not what
the patterns been so at this one I'm
rapidly losing faith in Marvel Netflix
product just as a thing I'm not sure how
much hope I have for daredevil season 3
or any of the other shows at all at this
point but Jessica Jones I really really
want the second season to be good and
what we see in this trailer is fairly
promising all things considered first of
all she is she's still on she really
Krysten Ritter really does this part
extremely well she's really good in it
she manages to be wonderfully abrasive
to people around her and yet still be
endearing to at least to me as an
audience member so that
they strike that balance really well we
don't get a heck of a lot of plot
detailing this it's just it's basically
she's back
here's that attitude that she had before
hope you like did it before cuz its back
again and in my case I did like it
before so I'm happy to see it back I am
a little bit concerned that it looks
like they're gonna be picking up the
threads at the end of the first season
about possibly looking into her origins
now my familiarity with Jessica Jones
from the comics because I have read some
of them is not so deep that I can say
for certain whether or not the comics
ever delved into the origin of her
powers I don't think they ever did
though I think this is kind of new
territory for the show to be exploring
which normally I would praise because it
means you can potentially surprise even
the folks who have read the comics by
going to slightly different direction
Mining some stuff that maybe hasn't been
mined in the comics but at the same time
really concerns me because inherently I
don't care I mean where Jessica got her
powers from is not a question that I
particularly need to have answered it
has almost nothing to do with the appeal
she holds for me as a character I mean
functionally the only reason her powers
matter at all is she can take a punch
better than most people I mean she's not
a Luke Cage or an iron fist or a
daredevil level fighter she can throw
down and it helps that people
underestimate her but well you know I'll
just quote my partner on this her
sarcasm is a more impressive superpower
than her actual superpowers and again I
like that she has superpowers but
they're they're just an element they're
an icing to me they're not something I
need delved into particularly and the
other reason I'm nervous about this is
that trying to go a mystery story is
where a lot of the Marvel Netflix shows
have fallen down I mean they tried to
build a whole lot of mystery and a whole
lot of different shows around the hand
and that never worked worth a darn they
did it a little bit with luque shina
build this mystique with Diamondback but
the execution of that didn't work you
know they you know again more of the
hand and the defenders and I just feel
like mystery aspects and conspiracies
and secrets is something that the
Netflix shows keep going back to
but actually don't really do
particularly well there was not a whole
ton of secrecy mystery in that first
season of daredevil there was a little
but it didn't drive the story like he
had the introduction of the hand with
that one really cool ninja and you had
your hints at Fisk and then he showed up
and he was basically exactly what you
expected him to be and Jessica Jones
again was a deep dive into characters
and their damage and was not built
around you know try unveiling a mystery
even though she's a detective and that
would that would theoretically fit in
but the seasons that I've liked the best
had that element in them the least the
seasons I really don't like leaned on it
a lot harder so the the whole fact that
that's present concerns me now if I'm
lucky
it doesn't drive the narrative
excessively because I basically I want
Jessica to get back on the job cuz I
have started reading you know the alias
I haven't read her new stuff and what's
kind of really interesting is the way
that different cases that she takes on
what they say about her her place in the
world the world in general and also what
they bring out of her and what they
reveal about her as a character so I
think it's totally valid to just focus
on have her work a case for a while I
mean it'd probably be hard to stretch it
out a whole season but just have a work
a case a couple of episodes and another
case a couple more episodes and I'm
about to get into something that is
potentially a spoiler um if you've been
going out of your way to avoid any news
about the second season so if that's the
case you might want to bow out right now
but that is we know kilgrave returns in
some capacity because there were images
of David Tennant on the set whether he
is just a memory or just sort of the
lingering trauma for Jessica or whether
his powers when they were boosted by his
father actually kind of literally put
him in our mind to some degree we don't
really know but you know that sort of
thing would be a good through line to
give us for the season the lingering
damage the lingering consequences which
we also got a bit of a hint at
because you know she talks about it and
you know having killed somebody and that
seems to really be weighing on her as
much as having done so in the moment I'm
sure was greatly cathartic but she now
has to deal with that so I like that
there are consequences so I am still
hopeful I'm just I'm just nervous I'm
just nervous based on the track record
for recent Netflix shows that just
haven't worked for me personally and I'm
nervous because the one real strong hint
we get at story and where it's going is
something that I'm not interested in and
is the kind of thing these shows have
been screwing up so I'm still really
hopeful it's coming out in March which
will put it out around my birthday so
that'd be a wonderful birthday present
if it's really good
please so those are my thoughts on the
first trailer for a season two of
Jessica Jones have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
Council of geeks podcast that is
available on Apple podcast and stitcher
radio I'm also 1/2 of the punch like a
girl podcast that is a presentation of
the fire and water podcast network
Fire & Water podcast comm and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]